Todd Howard has directed both fallout 4  and Skyrim and he's got big plans for  whatever bethesda does next speaking at  the 2016 dice summit he was asked about  what the studio is working on and he  mentioned a few upcoming projects saying  we have three longer-term projects we're  doing that are all we'll talk about them  at a much future date but they're  different than anything we've done  before while also being a Bethesda style  game big and crazy but in many ways  different than things we've done before  considering Bethesda's other games the  sky really is the limit for that team  Howard also mentioned that there's a  secret and fallout 4 no one has found  yet he wouldn't say much only that it's  related to a terminal we'll have to do  some digging in the meantime we've got  plenty of information from the other  dice panels on gamespot and for all the  bethesda news you're already in the  right place